this video is sponsored by kiskit more
details later in the video
from the first idea of a quantum
computer in 1980 to today there's been a
huge growth in the quantum computing
industry especially in the last 10 years
with dozens of companies and startups
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
in a race to build the world's best
quantum computers
for most of us it's quite hard to get
our heads around the world of quantum
computing and a lot of information about
it glosses over important details
this video aims to clear all this up and
if you watch the whole thing you'll have
a very good overview of the different
kinds of quantum computing how they work
and why so many people are investing in
the quantum computing industry
this is the map of quantum computing
quantum computers solve problems in a
different way to the computers we're
familiar with which from now on i'll be
referring to as classical computers
quantum computers have certain
advantages over normal computers for
certain problems which comes from their
ability to be in a huge number of states
at the same time whereas classical
computers can only be in one state at a
time
to understand this and to understand how
quantum computers work you need to
understand three things superposition
entanglement and interference
the building blocks of a classical
computer are called bits and the
building blocks of a quantum computer
are called quantum bits or qubits for
short and they work in fundamentally
different ways
a classical bit is kind of like a switch
that can either be a zero or a one which
you're probably already familiar with as
binary or binary information
when we measure a bit we just get back
the state that it's currently in but
we'll see this isn't true of qubits a
qubit is more complicated for a useful
visualization you can think of them as
an arrow pointing in 3d space if they
point up they're in the zero state and
if they point down they're in the one
state just like a classical bit
but they also have the option to be in a
thing called a superposition state which
is when the arrow points in any other
direction
this superposition state is a
combination state of zero and one
now when you measure a qubit the output
it gives will still end up being either
a zero or a one
but which one you get depends on a
probability which is set by the
direction of the arrow
if the arrow is pointing more upwards
you're more likely to get back a zero
than a one
and if it's pointing downwards you're
more likely to get a one than a zero
and if it's exactly on the equator
you'll get either state with a 50
probability
so that's the effect of superposition
explained now we'll move on to
entanglement
in a classical computer the bits are
independent from each other the state of
one bit is not influenced by the state
of any of the other bits
but in quantum computers the qubits can
be entangled with each other which means
they become part of one large quantum
state together
for an example let's look at two qubits
which are each in different
superposition states but aren't
entangled yet
you can see the probabilities next to
them and these probabilities are
currently independent of each other
but when we entangle them we have to
throw away those independent
probabilities and calculate a
probability distribution of all the
possible states we can get out either 0
0 0 1 1 0 or 1 1.
the important point here is because the
qubits are entangled if you change the
direction of the arrow on one qubit it
changes the probability distribution for
the whole system
so the qubits are no longer independent
of each other they are all part of the
same large state
and this is true no matter how many
qubits you have
you'll also note that for one qubit
you've got a probability distribution
over two states for two qubits you've
got a probability distribution over four
states for three qubits you've got a
distribution over eight states and this
keeps on doubling each time you add
another qubit
in general a quantum computer of n
qubits can be in a combination of two to
the power of n states
so i'd say that this is the core
difference between classical computers
and quantum computers
classical computers can be in any state
you want but can only be in one state at
a time whereas quantum computers can be
in a superposition of all of those
states at the same time but you may
wonder how being in the superposition
state can be useful in a computer well
for that we need the final component
interference
to explain the effect of interference we
need to go back and look at my picture
of a qubit technically called a bloch
sphere
now a cubit doesn't actually look like
this this is just a really nice way of
visualizing the state of a qubit in
reality the state of a qubit is
described by a more abstract entity
known as a quantum wave function
wave functions are the fundamental
mathematical description of everything
in quantum mechanics which i've
described in more detail in a previous
video
when you've got many qubits entangled
together all of their wave functions are
added together into an overall wave
function describing the state of the
quantum computer this adding together of
wave functions is the interference
because just like we say ripples of
water when we add waves together they
can constructively interfere and add
together to make a bigger wave or
destructively interfere to cancel each
other out
the overall wave function of the quantum
computer is what sets the different
probabilities of the different states
and by changing the states of different
qubits we can change the probabilities
that different states will come out when
we measure the quantum computer remember
that even though the quantum computer
can be in a superposition of millions of
states at the same time when we measure
it we only get a single state out
so when you're using a quantum computer
to solve a computation problem you need
to use constructive interference to
increase the probability of the correct
answer and use destructive interference
to decrease the probabilities of the
incorrect answers so that when you
measure it the correct answer will come
out
now how you do this is in the realm of
quantum algorithms and the whole
motivation behind quantum computers is
that theoretically there are a bunch of
problems that you can solve on a quantum
computer that are thought to be
intractable on classical computers so
let's take a look at them there are many
quantum algorithms too many to describe
in this video so we'll just focus on the
most famous and historically important
shaw's algorithm
if you've got two large numbers and you
multiply them together there's a fast
efficient classical algorithm for
finding the answer however if you start
with the answer and ask what are the
original numbers that multiply together
to make this number it's a lot more
difficult
this is known as factorization and these
numbers are called factors and the
reason finding them is so hard is
because the search space of possible
factors is so large and there's no
efficient classical algorithm for
finding the factors of large numbers
for this reason we use this mathematical
property for internet encryption secure
websites emails and bank accounts
if you know these factors you can easily
decrypt and view the information but if
you don't you need to work them out
first which is intractable on the
world's most powerful computers which is
why in 1994 when peter shaw published a
fast quantum algorithm that can
efficiently find the factors of large
integers it caused quite the stir
this is the moment that a lot of people
started to take the idea of quantum
computing seriously because it was the
first application to a real world
problem with potentially huge real world
security implications
but when i say a fast quantum algorithm
how fast and how much faster than a
classical computer would it be well to
answer these questions we need to take a
little detour into the world of quantum
complexity theory
quantum complexity theory is a subfield
for the world of computational
complexity theory which deals with the
categorization of algorithms sorting
them into bins according to how well
they run on computers
the categorization is based on how much
harder it is to solve a problem as the
problem gets larger
here any problem inside the p box is
easy to solve with a classical computer
but anything outside it means we don't
have an efficient classical algorithm to
solve them and factoring large numbers
is one of these
but there's one box here bqp which is
efficient for a quantum computer but not
a classical computer and these are the
problems that quantum computers will be
better than classical computers at
solving
as i said complexity theory looks at how
difficult it is to solve a problem as
the problem gets larger
so if you factorize a number with eight
digits then you add another digit on how
much harder is it to factor the new
number compared to the old one is it
twice as hard or exponentially harder
and what's the trend as you add more and
more digits
this is called its complexity or scaling
and for factorization it's exponential
these exponential problems are the
problems that really screw you over as
the problems get bigger and in the world
of computer science you can win respect
and renown if you find a better
algorithm to solve these hardest
problems
one example of this was shaw's algorithm
which took advantage of the special
features of quantum computers to create
an algorithm that could solve integer
factorization with a scaling much better
than the best classical algorithm
the best classical algorithm is
exponential whereas shaw's algorithm is
polynomial which is a huge deal in the
world of complexity theory in computer
science in general because it turns an
intractable problem into a problem that
can be solved solved that is if you have
a working quantum computer which is what
people are working on building
but you don't need to worry about the
security of your bank account yet
because today's quantum computers are
not able to run shaw's algorithm on
large numbers yet
i've estimated that they need about a
million qubits to do so but so far the
most advanced universal quant computers
have around a hundred
also people are working on what's known
as post quantum encryption schemes which
don't use integer factorization
and another technology from the world of
quantum physics can help here too a
cryptographic scheme known as quantum
cryptography
so that was a look at just one quantum
algorithm but they're many more each
with different levels of speed up
another notable example is grover's
algorithm which can search unstructured
lists of data faster than the best
classical algorithm
but i should be careful here to make
sure i don't miss characterized
classical computers they are very
versatile devices and there's nothing to
say that someone may find a very clever
classical algorithm that could solve the
hardest problems like integer
factorization more efficiently
people think it's very unlikely but it's
not ruled out
also there are problems that we can
prove are impossible to solve on
classical computers called
non-computable problems like the halting
problem
but these are also impossible to solve
on a quantum computer so computationally
classical computers and quantum
computers are equivalent to each other
the differences all come from the
algorithms that they can run
you can even simulate a quantum computer
on a classical computer and vice versa
but simulating a quantum computer on a
classical computer gets exponentially
harder to do the more qubits you're
trying to simulate
this is because classical computers
struggle to simulate quantum systems
but because quantum computers are
already quantum systems they don't have
this problem which brings me to my
favorite application of quantum
computers quantum simulation
quantum simulation is simulating things
like chemical reactions or how electrons
behave in different materials with a
computer
here quantum computers also have an
exponential speed up over classical
computers because classical computers
really struggle to simulate quantum
systems
now i've made a whole other video about
quantum simulation which you can watch
here but basically simulating quantum
systems with as few as 30 particles is
difficult even on the world's most
powerful supercomputers
we also can't do this on quantum
computers yet but as they mature a main
goal is to be able to simulate larger
and larger quantum systems
these include areas like the behavior of
exotic materials at low temperatures
like understanding what makes some
material superconduct or studying
important chemical reactions to improve
their efficiency one example aims to
produce fertilizer in a way that emits
way less carbon dioxide as fertilizer
production contributes to about two
percent of global carbon emissions
other potential applications of quantum
stimulation include improving solar
panels improving batteries developing
new drugs or chemicals or materials for
aerospace
in general quantum simulation would mean
that we'd be able to rapidly prototype
many different materials inside a
quantum computer and test all of their
physical parameters instead of having to
physically make them and test them in a
lab which is a much more laborious and
expensive process
this could be a lot faster and save a
huge amount of time and money
but it's worth reiterating that all of
these are potential applications of
quantum computers because we don't have
any quantum computers that can solve
real world problems better than our
normal computers yet but these are the
kinds of problems that quant computers
would be well suited to
other applications outside of quantum
simulation are optimization problems
machine learning and ai financial
modelling weather forecasting and
climate change which i'll be honest i
don't really understand how that would
work
and finally cyber security which i think
just boils down to shaw's algorithm
which i've already described
now we need to be a little careful about
the potential for hype here as a lot of
the claims of what quantum computers
will be good for come from people who
are actively raising money to build them
so it makes sense for them to piggyback
on topical subjects in their pictures
but my take on this is that historically
when a new technology has come along
people of the time aren't generally the
best at being able to tell what it's
going to be used for for example the
people who first invented the computers
never dreamed of the internet and
all of the things on it
and this is likely to be the same for
quantum computers so for me the
application i can really understand is
quantum simulation and that's that's why
i focused on that in this video
anyway so far i've described how quantum
computers work and what problems they
can solve
but most of what i've talked about so
far is theoretical and for the rest of
the video i want to focus on reality how
are people actually building on
computers and what can they actually do
now it's worth mentioning here that some
physicists are skeptical that it will
ever be possible to build a quant
computer at the scale needed to solve
real world problems but the people
working on all of the following
certainly don't agree now quantum
computing is often portrayed as if it's
a single thing but inside the world of
quantum computers there's a large range
of approaches to turning different kinds
of quantum systems into quantum
computers and there's two layers of
nuance i need to talk about
first of all are the models of quantum
computing the overall approach to
manipulating a collection of qubits and
then there's the physical
implementations the actual quantum
objects you build your qubits from like
a superconducting loop or individual
atoms or photons
we'll start with the models of quantum
computing
it's interesting that there are
different models of quantum computing
because this isn't something we see with
classical computers
practically all the computers we use
today work in the same way they have a
bunch of bits holding the binary
information of ones and zeros and we can
do operations on those bits using
logical gates which are basically simple
operations that flip a bit called a not
gate or compare bits like for example
giving you a one if both input bits are
zero or a zero if they're anything else
this is called a nor gate interestingly
you can build a full general purpose
computer from just bits and nor gates
in quantum computing there's a similar
model to this called the circuit model
or gate model which is the most popular
approach and the most understood model
in quantum computing
in the circuit model you have your
collection of qubits which are entangled
with each other and then you have a
bunch of gates which can perform
operations on small numbers of these
qubits which change the state of the
qubits without measuring them
a quantum algorithm is built from a
sequence of gates applied to the qubit
in a certain order and then a
measurement at the end which is where
you get your final state and is
hopefully the answer to the problem
you're trying to solve
simplistically you can think of these
gates as operations on the qubits that
rotate the arrows to point in different
directions and these operations change
the probability of the final state of
each qubit when it's finally measured
now there's more to this which i don't
have time to explain here but if you
want to learn more about them and do
some quantum computing yourself i highly
recommend the educational website and
youtube channel called kisskit
they're very kindly sponsoring this
video and honestly they're the best
resource for people who want to learn
more about quantum computing and get
some actual hands-on experience
basically kiskit is a software framework
funded by ibm to make it easier for
people to get into the world of quantum
computing
everything there is free to access and
all the code is open source and there's
an online textbook which teaches you all
of the basics so if you don't have a
quantum physics background that's not a
problem at all you can learn everything
you need there
their kiss kit youtube channel is also
full of excellent tutorials and lectures
i'll link to all of this below and in
terms of quantum algorithms you can run
through examples of quantum circuits
using their online tools and if you want
to run your own quantum programs you can
download their open source sdk and run
them on ibm hardware either on classical
simulators or quantum computers or on
actual real-world quantum computers all
for free also the sdk is not only tied
to ibm hardware i used to work at
another quantum computer company called
d-wave and there's an interface to their
computers as well in the sdk if you want
to learn about their approach called
quantum annealing and many other
companies are available too
personally i've been using their website
to learn gate model quantum computing
deeper because my background's in
quantum annealing and i'm super happy
that this educational resource exists
and is free to use so please check that
out if you want to dig deeper finally i
just want to state that i've had
complete editorial control over the
content in this video and my goal is
always to be as objective as i can i
just want to make sure you know that
kiskit is funded by ibm who are building
quantum computers and i used to work for
d-wave who are also making other kinds
of quantum computers just for
transparency so you know everyone's
backgrounds
right back to the models of quantum
computing
we've already looked at the circuit
model but closely related to it is
measurement based or one-way quantum
computing which involves setting up an
initial entangled state and then
measuring qubits one by one during the
computation and mathematically this has
been shown to be equivalent to the
circuit model
now let's look at the models i'm most
familiar with adiabatic quantum
computing and quantum annealing
adiabatic quantum computing works in a
very different way to the circuit model
in adiabatic quantum computing you're
taking advantage of one of the
fundamental behaviors in physics the
fact that every system in physics always
moves towards the minimum energy state
this is a very general principle and
adiabatic quantum computing takes
advantage of this by posing the problems
you want solved in such a way so that
the minimum energy state of the quantum
system is the answer to the problem
you can picture this as an energy
landscape where each point on the
landscape is one of the potential
outputs of the computer in adiabatic
quantum computing you start off with a
flat landscape and gradually introduce
the energy landscape of your problem
where the answer to your problem is the
lowest position on the map
if you do this slowly enough the quant
computer will always stay in the lowest
energy state so that when you measure it
you're most likely to get the correct
answer
i should mention that i'm having to
simplify things a bit here to make it
easier to understand but it gives you
the right picture of what's going on in
reality i need to talk about
hamiltonians and eigenstates but that's
beyond the scope of this video
even though adiabatic quantum computing
is so different to the circuit model
they have been shown to be
mathematically equivalent and problems
can be mapped from one to the other
and they're both something called a
universal quantum computing scheme which
means that theoretically they can
simulate any quantum system
strongly related to adiabatic quantum
computing is quantum annealing which is
not a universal computing scheme but
works on the same principle as adiabatic
quantum computing with the system
finding the minimum energy state of an
energy landscape that you give it
the reason it's not universal is because
it doesn't have the full degrees of
freedom to represent any quantum state
but even with this limitation it can
still be used to solve certain energy
landscape problems like optimization
problems and simulate certain quantum
systems an example is spin glasses which
are grids of magnetic fields connected
to each other
and quantum annealing is a stepping
stone to building a universal adiabatic
quantum computer
the last model we're going to look at is
called topological quantum computing
which is currently the most theoretical
model of quantum computing because it
builds its qubits from an entity in
physics called a majorana zero mode
quasi-particle which is a type of
non-abelian anion
which is a bit of a mouthful and
obviously quite confusing but the the
important term here is a quasi particle
quasi particles aren't fundamental
particles like atoms or electrons or
photons quasi particles are created from
the collected behavior of many particles
together and end up having particle-like
properties despite not being actually
real
the clearest example of this is an
electron hole
if you have a grid of an electrons with
a gap in the middle as the electrons
fill in the gap it looks like this hole
moves in the opposite direction this
hole isn't real it's just a hole but you
can treat it like a particle with
particle-like properties
in condensed matter physics there are a
large range of different kinds of
quasi-particle and a majorana zero mode
quasiparticle is an entity that's been
theoretically predicted but there's
still significant debate over whether
they've actually been experimentally
observed or not
now the reason why physicists are
excited about this model is because
these quasi-particles are predicted to
be a lot more stable than other qubits
because they're made from parts which
are physically separated from each other
this is good because the main source of
failure in a quantum computer is noise
which comes from rogue forms of energy
creeping into the quantum computer
making the qubits drift away from where
they should be and causing errors
but these quasi particles are special
because they're protected from the noise
by an energy gap basically what this
means is it takes a certain amount of
energy to bring the parts of a majorana
particle back together so any
perturbations of noise which have a
lower energy than that energy gap is not
felt by the quasi-particle
this might have been a bit confusing but
that's okay i'm still getting my head
around them too but that's the best
boiled down description i could come up
with
okay so that rounds up the different
models of quantum computation but how do
you actually build them
there are a huge range of different
physical implementations of quantum
computers because there's so many
different quantum systems that you could
potentially build them from
the requirements to build a qubit is
actually fairly simple all you need is a
two-state quantum system where one state
will represent zero and the other will
represent one
the most obvious example of this is the
spin of a particle the spin can be up or
down but as we shall see there are many
properties of particles we can use in
fact there are too many for me to list
them all so i'm just going to focus on
the implementations that are the most
widely used and have been the most
successful so far
but no matter what the approach is they
all face a similar set of obstacles
which we need to take a look at first
in general it's really hard to control
quantum systems because if you've got
any slight interaction with the outside
world the information starts leaking
away this is called decoherence
you want your qubits to be entangled
with each other but you don't want them
to be entangled with anything else but
the trouble is your qubits will be made
of physical stuff and you'll need other
physical stuff nearby to control and
measure them
and your qubits are dumb they'll
entangle with anything they can see
so you need to design your cubits very
carefully to protect them from
entangling with the environment
then you need to shield your qubits from
any kind of noise things like cosmic
rays or radiation from things like phone
calls or heat energy or any other kind
of rogue particle
unfortunately some amount of decoherence
and noise is inevitable in any physical
system and is impossible to eliminate
completely
and it gets worse the more qubits you
have entangled with each other this is
the big open question still hanging over
the whole field of quantum computing is
it ever possible to make a working
quantum computer with a large number of
qubits or will decoherence and noise
ruin everything
there are strong opinions on both sides
and i guess we won't know for sure until
we actually build them one plan to deal
with decoherence and noise is quantum
error correction this is an error
correction scheme to make fault tolerant
quantum computers by using many
entangled qubits together to represent
one noise free qubit how many you need
to group together depends on how good
the qubits are but estimates are in the
range of a hundred to a thousand
physical qubits to make one false
tolerant qubit which is a lot of
and this brings us to another major
obstacle scalability
for each qubit you need to have a bunch
of wires to manipulate and measure it
for a small number of qubits this is all
manageable but as the number of qubits
increases the amounts of extra stuff you
need increases linearly which is a
massive engineering problem so any
quantum computer design needs to somehow
be able to entangle all of the qubits
and then control and measure them in a
scalable way
so those are all the problems with
building a real quantum computer let's
now take a look at the different
approaches scientists are pursuing
superconducting quantum computers are
currently the most popular approach a
superconducting qubit is made from
superconducting wires with a break in
the superconductor called a josephson
junction
the most popular type of superconducting
qubit is called a transmon where the two
energy level system is encoded in pairs
of the electric charge moving across the
junction specifically the frequency at
which charges oscillate back and forth
across the junction but there have been
other designs that use the magnetic flux
in a loop of wire or the phase across a
wire as the two level system known as a
flux qubit or a phase qubit
physicists have also looked at ways of
making qubits out of fundamental
entities like atoms or electrons or
photons
quantum dot quantum computers or silicon
spin quantum computers
here i'm using quantum dot quantum
computers to collect together a range of
qubit designs built from semiconductors
things like silicon
here the qubits are made from electrons
or even groups of electrons and the two
level system is encoded into the spin or
charge of the electrons
on the chip there's a small area where
the electron is restricted to and this
is called a quantum dot
and operations on the qubits are
performed through voltages on the chip
or microwaves or magnetic fields
as well as silicon people have also used
other semiconducting materials like
gallium arsenide silicon carbide and
also diamond amongst others and these
have all got different properties
next we have linear optical quantum
computing
optical quantum computers use photons of
light as the qubits and they operate on
these qubits using optical elements like
mirrors wave plates and
interferometers at scale this has been
accomplished by printing these elements
into integrated photonics chips
the two level system in an optical quant
computer can have different designs
either a superposition of different
paths a single photon takes through the
chip or a superposition of different
numbers of photons present in a path and
these can be manipulated by applying a
voltage to a path
now onto trapped ion quantum computers
which use charged atoms as the qubits
these atoms are ionized having a missing
electron which makes them electrically
charged and means that they can be
levitated and moved about with
electromagnetic fields here the two
level state that encodes the qubits are
two specific energy levels of the atom
which can be manipulated or measured
with microwaves or laser beams
next we have colour center or nitrogen
vacancy quantum computers which is
similar to trapped ion quantum computers
in that the qubits are made from atoms
but instead of being trapped in an
electromagnetic field they're embedded
in a gap of the material like nitrogen
embedded in diamond or silicon carbide
there are a few different ways to make
these but typically the qubits are the
nucleus spins of the embedded atoms and
they're entangled together with
electrons
the final approach is called neutral
atoms in optical lattices
in this approach the qubits are atoms
and the design uses cold atom physics
capturing neutral atoms like cesium into
an optical lattice which is a
criss-crossed arrangement of laser beams
which form energy wells shaped kind of
like an egg box
these atoms are cooled down with lasers
to a few millionths of a kelvin and
there's a number of ways to encode the
two level system the qubits built from
either the hyperfine energy level of the
atom or excited states and they can also
make use of rydeberg atoms and the atoms
can be controlled and entangled with
each other with lasers
they can also be used as quantum
simulators as well as quantum computers
in fact a 10 000 atom quantum simulator
has been made but this doesn't look like
a universal quant computer
these are the main approaches i'm going
to cover in this video but it's not an
exhaustive list some other qubit designs
include electron on helium qubits cavity
quantum electrodynamics magnetic
molecules or molecular spins and nmr
quantum computers
but these haven't been built at the same
scale as the other approaches i
mentioned in more detail
so that was the map of quantum computing
and that should give you an excellent
overview of the field as you can see
there are many different approaches to
building a quantum computer and what's
so interesting is that it's not yet
clear which approach will win out in the
long run
now one thing i haven't covered in this
video are the companies and startups and
which approach they're using along with
their current best quantum computers and
their road maps into the future
but this is what i'll look at in the
next video so keep your eyes peeled for
that you don't need to subscribe or
anything but check back in a couple of
weeks if you think you'd be interested
and like all of my maps this map of
quantum computing is available to buy at
my store dosmaps.com or to download as a
digital image for educational purposes
links to all of that in the description
below quick note though due to logistics
we can only get the map of quantum
computing to you after the holidays but
everything else in my store is ready to
go we also have many educational posters
and a range of engaging kids books about
science called professor astrocat so if
you're looking for some gifts that will
help your loved ones learn about science
check that out dustmaps.com
finally a massive thank you to all of my
patreon supporters as you can probably
tell i put a huge amount of work into
these map videos and the support on
patreon is invaluable
thank you and i'll see you soon
you